have you ever wondered what makes Amish
life so unique today I'll take you
inside their world feeding chickens
grains all day is like giving a teenager
nothing but chips and sood easy but far
from my deal I used to feed my chickens
grains because the feed store convinced
me and the bag had a picture of a Happy
Hen I figured why not but my chickens
weren't thrilled they ate some but spent
most of the day scattering it around
like confetti egg production barely
average it felt like I was paying a
premium for junk food grains are a go to
for most chicken owners much like people
once believed bloodletting cured
everything it's just something people
did even though it wasn't the best
option but the Amish do things
differently forget expensive bags of
grain they managed to feed their
chickens for just
$125 a week honestly I've spent more
than that on a single bad coffee maybe
you're thinking but my chickens love
grains of course they do just like kids
love candy chickens are omnivores
they're designed to scratch for bugs
plants and whatever else they can find
grains are just a small part of their
natural diet feeding them only grains is
like making them sit on a couch watching
TV all day fun at first but not healthy
longterm switching to the Amish method
wasn't just about saving money though
that was a nice perk my chickens became
healthier more active and started laying
better eggs it was like upgrading their
diet from fast food to Gourmet Plus plus
I wasn't constantly running to buy more
grain every 2 weeks did you know that
wild chickens eat more bugs and seeds
than grains they need variety and when
they get it they Thrive grains that's
just filler at first I thought the $1
and 25 cents a week claim sounded to
good to be true but after a few weeks
the results were clear healthier
chickens a happier wallet and less mess
from scattered grain it was a win-win
one you see how well this works it's
hard to go back to the old ways when I
first heard the Amish could feed their
chickens for
$125 a week I thought I'd M her I was
spending way more on grain and my
chickens weren't exactly rewarding me
with extra eggs I had to see for myself
what the Amish were doing differently
that's how I ended up visiting an Amish
farm honestly I expected them to pull
out some old-fashioned farming Gadget
like a hand cranked grain grinder but no
they didn't seem to have any special
tools the Amish have a knack for making
everything look simple and their chicken
feeding system was no exception while I
was lugging heavy bags of grain and
scooping out portions like a cafeteria
worker they were tossing out kitchen
scraps letting their chickens forage and
using fermented feed their chickens were
running around pecking at bugs plants
and kitchen leftovers I couldn't believe
how much easier their system was it was
like watching someone effortlessly cook
a gmet meal while you struggle with
microwave popcorn about that
$125 cost I thought it couldn't be real
I did the math assuming they had to be
leaving something out but no their
method was incredibly costeffective
meanwhile I was spending a small fortune
on grain my chickens barely liked the
Amish succeed By ignoring the grain hype
that feed companies push instead they
use things that would otherwise go to
waste vegetable peels stale bread and
leftover salad it's like they created a
sustainable farm twoot table Chicken
buffet minus the fancy Vibe what amazed
me most was how natural it all felt
there chickens were free to forage
finding bugs and plants while the
fermented feed extended their food
supply I'd never heard of feeding
chickens fermented food but these
chickens loved it it was like a
five-star meal for them the process was
so simple it felt almost to good to be
true but it made perfect sense the Amish
have been doing things their way for
Generations no gadgets no flashy
marketing and definitely no overpriced
grain bags yet their chickens were
thriving so what do the Amish feed their
chickens if not grains when I asked I
half expected some secret ingredient but
there was no mystery they rely on Common
Sense and scraps most people throw away
kitchen leftovers fermented feed and
whatever the chickens can find while
foraging I thought the secret would be
something unusual like magic beans but
no there's no mystery here the Amish
rely on good old fashion practicality
and a combination of things you'd
usually throw away without a second
thought we're talking about kitchen
scraps fermented feed and whatever
chickens can scavenge it's not fancy but
it works and at just
$125 a week I'm not complaining let's
start with kitchen scraps if you're like
me you probably dislike wasting food you
cook dinner end up with some peels or a
few stale bread slices and into the
trash they go but not the Amish they've
turned feeding chickens into a recycling
Masterpiece veggie peels leftover salad
and rock hard bread become chicken
delices for chickens it's as good as
fresh baked croissants the Amish have
mastered turning food waste into a
Powerhouse for egg production then
there's fermented feed at first I
imagined some odd science project with
jars bubbling away and strange smells in
reality it's much simpler fermented feed
is just ordinary feed like cracked
grains so in water until it ferments the
fermentation process introduces healthy
bacteria that improve the chicken's
digestion much like how yogurt benefits
us plus the feed swells as it ferments
meaning less feed is needed to satisfy
the chickens foraging is where things
get really interesting chickens are
natural scavengers they love scratching
around for bugs warms and whatever they
can find in the dirt you've probably
seen them do this countless times but
have you ever thought about what they're
actually ually after bugs of course
chickens are like tiny feathered
dinosaurs with an instinct to hunt when
they forage they're getting protein from
insects and the best part it costs
nothing bugs are completely free you
might think really bugs and scraps
that's it and yes it sounds almost to
simple but that's the beauty of it
chickens aren't picky they'll eat just
about anything you give them when you
combine the right scraps with foraging
they Thrive this approach leads to
healthier chickens and healthier
chickens lay better eggs think about it
if you ate the same meal every day you'd
get bored too by giving chickens a mix
of scraps and the chance to forage the
Amish create a more natural and diverse
diet for their Birds the result happier
healthier chickens and fewer trips to
the feed store saving you money in the
process the next time you throw away
potato peels or a half eaten sandwich
remember that you're tossing out free
chicken feed Meanwhile your chickens
could be foraging for VMS living their
best lives and giving you high quality
eggs in return transitioning chickens
from a grain-based diet to this Amish
style approaches like swapping fast food
for gourmet home-cooked meals you
wouldn't want to live on junk food every
day and neither do your chickens the
change is obvious almost immediately the
first thing you'll notice is the eggs
the difference between eggs from
grain-fed chickens and those on this
nutrient trich diet is like comparing
fast food to a homemade Feast the eggs
have a richer color color better flavor
and more nutrients I'll never forget
cracking my first egg after switching my
chicken's diet the yolk was so vibrantly
oranged that it seemed magical but it
was just the result of better nutrition
the combination of foraged bugs
fermented feed and kitchen scraps
creates a nutrient packed diet which
leads to Superior egg quality studies
confirm it chickens on a varied and
nutrient Rich diet produce eggs with
higher levels of vitamins feeding your
chickens this way is like giving them
fresh organic local ingredients instead
of cheap mass produced filler it's
better for them and better for you
vitamins like a ande plus omega-3 South
are a GameChanger these nutrients make
you feel like you're getting your
money's worth at the store but it's not
just the eggs that benefit the chickens
themselves look and feel like they've
just come back from a spar Retreat their
feathers become shinier they stop
shedding so much and their overall Vibe
shifts from just surviving to thriving
it's as if they're auditioning for some
kind of chicken reality show honestly
they even seem happier if chickens could
smile mine would be grinning ear to air
their health improves too which means
fewer illnesses and thankfully fewer
trips to the vet let's be real giving
medicine to a chicken is like trying to
bathe a cat but with feathers and way
more noise Since switching to the Amish
method sick days have become rare the
chickens are tougher healthier and
handle challenges like bad weather or
stray dogs much better
it's as if they've been training for the
chicken Olympics and the Amish diet is
their secret weapon egg production also
gets a noticeable boost my hens used to
legs sure but not as consistently as
they do now grain heavy diets weighed
them down much like car bloating before
a race chickens may not run marathons
but the Amish diet makes them lighter
and more energetic the difference was
clear I didn't need a spreadsheet to see
the Improvement a full egg carton every
week was proof enough
I started feeling like I had cracked the
Cat my chickens were healthier laying
more eggs and I was spending Less on
feed Meanwhile my neighbors kept buying
pricey grain that didn't deliver half as
much it's like discovering that a $5
Burger tastes just as good if not better
than the $20 version from a fancy
restaurant and here's a bonus less waste
Yes you heard that right grain heavy
diets produce more chicken poop because
surprise chickens aren't designed to eat
grains all day with the Amish diet their
food is used more efficiently meaning
fewer messes for you to clean if you've
ever had to rake a chicken yard you'll
know what a huge win this is after my
chickens adjusted to the new diet I felt
like I'd unlocked a secret formula for
keeping chickens more eggs healthier
birds and fewer vet bills it almost felt
to good to be true before this I thought
feeding chickens would cost me a fortune
you know the feeling walking into a feed
store grab grabbing a bag of grain and
wondering if you're feeding chickens or
a herd of cattle and it wasn't just the
cost there was always that nagging
question is this really the best way to
do it well now I can confidently say
there's a better cheaper alternative
let's talk about the grain if you're
like me you're probably spending a small
fortune on chicken feed those bags
disappear faster than socks in a dryer
the Amish method on the other hand costs
about the same as a cup of fancy coffee
per week just
$125 that's way less than I used to
spend on overpriced feed mixes that
promised Miracles but didn't deliver the
savings are real but the real game Cher
is how stressfree this method is back
when I relied on grain I was stuck in an
endless cycle of buying hauling and
storing bags of feed those bags are
deceptively heavy lugging them around
feels like unintentional strength
training plus storing them turn my
garage into a critter magnet now instead
of over price chicken food I feed my
flock with scraps from my kitchen and
let them forage in the yard fermenting
their feet is so easy it almost feels
like cheating it's also a relief not to
deal with picky chickens anymore if
you've ever shelled out for premium feed
only for your chickens to reject it you
know how frustrating it is switching to
the Amish diet put an end to those
judgmental chicken stairs my chickens
are happier Scavenging bugs and enjoying
fermented feed than they ever were with
grains they eat with the kind of
enthusiasm you expect on pizza night
which is satisfying to watch plus the
money I save on feed could easily go
toward a Netflix subscription or some
snacks to enjoy while watching it I
accidentally ended up in a strength
training class thanks to lugging heavy
feed bags not to mention the chaos in my
garage with stacks of feed inviting
every Critter in the neighborhood for a
feast but now instead of hauling
overpriced chicken feed I use kitchen
scraps and let my chickens forage in the
yard fermented feed is so easy to make
it feels feels like I'm cheating oh and
let's talk sanity there's nothing worse
than chickens turning their beaks up at
premium feed you know the feeling
spending money on top tier food only for
them to act like it's beneath them
switching to the Amish method ended
those judgmental chicken looks now they
happily hunt for bugs and devour
fermented feed my chickens eat with the
enthusiasm of kids on pizza night which
is satisfying to watch and if you're
hesitant think of the money saved enough
to finally afford that Flix subscription
or some snacks plus healthier chickens
mean fewer vet visits saving you even
more I used to think chickens were low
maintenance until I was hit with vet
bills that could have been avoided with
a better diet Since switching emergency
chicken care is practically a thing of
the past less stress fewer expenses and
healthier chickens it's a win all around
if you're tired of wasting money on feed
your chickens barely touch this method
is a lifesaver it's better for your
wallet better for for your chickens and
better for your peace of mind you'll
laugh at how simple and affordable it is
and both you and your chickens will be
grateful for the change now you might be
wondering if this method is complicated
I thought the same it seemed too good to
be true like those Furniture
instructions that leave you questioning
your life choices but to my surprise the
Amish way of feeding chickens is
ridiculously simple honestly it's easier
than making toast especially since I've
burned toast more times than I'd like to
admit yet I haven't messed up the
chicken feed once just take kitchen
scraps let them ferment a bit knot full
on sourkraut level mixed with water and
you're done your chickens are
essentially getting a homemade meal at
first I thought this method would
require extra effort and as someone who
barely functions before coffee I wasn't
thrilled but the best part once you get
into the habit of saving scraps and
prepping feed it practically runs itself
now even on busy mornings this routine
feels effortless instead of dragging
around heavy grain bags I give my
chickens leftovers from the fridge and
they love it it's also a great way to
make use of scraps that would have gone
to waste if there's one thing I've
learned it's that we tend to over
complicate things the Amish have
mastered the art of Simplicity I
expected this change to take time but
it's been surprisingly easy no fancy
equipment no complex systems just
straightforward old-fashioned
practicality this is as low maintenance
as it gets and coming from someone who
hits sze six times every morning that's
saying something if you're wondering
whether you're capable of doing this
trust me you absolutely are it's not
about being an expert it's about
understanding that sometimes the
simplest approaches are the most
effective plus you'll save yourself time
money and mental energy after all if you
can make a sandwich you already have the
skills to feed your chickens and if you
figured out how to reheat pizza so
without burning it you're basically a
pro now let's dive into what this
grain-free experiment really does for
your chickens over time think of it like
this when you swap fast food for a Clean
home-cooked Diet your body feels better
right the same principle applies to
chickens after a few weeks on the Amish
method your flock will look and feel as
rejuvenated as if they just returned
from a spar treat one of the first
things I noticed was their feathers a
well-fed happy chicken has a noticeable
glow were at least their plumage looks
fantastic it's like replacing a Shabby
old sweater with a brand new fluffy one
no more ragged or patchy looking birds
instead they were sleek and stylish
honestly if chickens had a fashion show
mine would have been on the runway their
new found confidence and vibrant Health
were clear then there was the egg
production while I wasn't expecting a
miracle the Amish diet didn't disappoint
not only did the quantity of eggs
increase but the quality also improved
significantly the yolks were richer the
shells were sturdier and my chickens
just seemed genuinely happier cracking
open one of those deep golden yolks felt
like getting a little piece of sunshine
all of this came from swapping expensive
grain feed for something closer to their
natural diet I was genuinely impressed
here's an interesting fact chickens on a
grain-free diet often lay up to 15% more
eggs than those on traditional
grain-based diets that huge but when
you're collecting eggs every morning it
adds up and it's definitely satisfying
it made me feel like I was running a
boutique Egg Farm another big plus was
how much healthier the chickens were
overall they needed fewer vet visits had
fewer health issues and caused me far
less stress when chickens aren't
overloading on grains they're less
likely to become overweight develop
fatty liver disease or turn into those
lethargic grumpy hens that just sit
around instead mine became active alert
and fully engaged in their environment
chickens that forage and scratch around
naturally are much healthier and believe
me much happier too every morning they
practically bounced out of the co-op
eager to hunt for bugs or Peck at the
scraps I gave them it was like they
turned into little chicken athletes
here's the real game changer fewer
health problems mean fewer trips to the
vet nobody enjoys dealing with sick
chickens not them and definitely not me
no chicken wants to be hauled off to to
the vet when they could be out enjoying
the sunshine and chasing Grasshoppers
and let's not even talk about those vet
bills thanks to the Amish method the
need for vet visits dropped
significantly and my wallet was just as
happy as my chickens in short the
benefits of this Method Keep piling up
and they're not just temporary once your
chickens start thriving on this diet the
rewards are long lasting